al momento del cierre de la frontera con
españa transcurre intranquilidad pese a
los múltiples inconvenientes que esta
medida causa sobre todo las personas que
hacen vida en esta zona hay ocho puntos
en la frontera entre portugal y españa-
que van a permanecer abiertos las 24
horas del día con controles en los que
sólo está permitido el paso a
trabajadores fronterizos vehículos de
emergencia transporte de mercancías del
lado de españa se encuentra la policía
nacional realizando estos controles y
del lado de portugal es la guardia
nacional republicana y el servicio de
extranjería y fronteras hay otros cinco
puntos que van a estar abiertos sólo
cuatro horas al día los días de semana y
otro punto en río de honor que estará
abierto solo miércoles y sábados entre
10 y 12 del mediodía también está
prohibida la circulación ferroviaria
entre portugal y españa
esta medida recordemos estará vigente
hasta el próximo 14 de febrero se ha
registrado ya personas que han sido
regresados de españa porque desconocían
la medida o no tenían el justificativo
para que las autoridades permitieran su
ingreso
hoy también entra en vigencia en
portugal una nueva medida para intentar
contener
la pandemia que ha causado el kobe 19 y
la prohibición a todos los ciudadanos
portugueses a salir del país bien sea
vía aérea marítima o terrestre también
hay excepciones